[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Jeff ciao
I'm an engineer at Heroku working on the
day team and specifically I work on the
team that provides Apache Kafka as a
service in today's talk we'll go over
some of the details regarding the
challenges we've encountered and had to
solve along the way but specifically
let's first cover some of the core
concepts and fundamentals of Kafka so
Kafka is essentially a distributed
messaging system and it consists of five
fundamental components they are brokers
topics and partitions and producers and
consumers now brokers are just
individual instances or processes of
Kafka that manage streams of messages
and these messages are categorized into
topics these topics may have one or more
partitions in which a partition is just
a right ahead log that writes messages
in the order that they are received and
stores them directly on disk now I would
like to point out that Kafka things in
terms of partitions where essentially
topics are just an abstraction for
groupings of partitions and with that
said partitions are Kafka's fundamental
building blocks for parallelism and
message ordering and lastly topics but
specifically their partitions are
replicated across brokers so that's for
the server side now on the client side
we have producers and consumers and
these guys simply just write to or read
from a topic where a producer although
it writes a topic more specifically it
writes to specific partitions determined
by some key and otherwise we have
consumers which simply just read from
their assigned partitions so pretty
straightforward so far but the
interesting thing about consumer
is that they maintain their own offsets
or progress of where they read up to for
each partition now why is this useful
because this means that consumers can
process at their own speeds be it faster
or slow but in addition to that
consumers can individually recover their
progress on a failure now this is all
great conceptually but when it comes to
operating Kafka there are many things to
consider when dealing with it at scale
it might not be as easy as you think for
instance how do you deal with
replication or how does Kafka achieve a
che
then there's quota management and
security as in how do we prevent abuse
from misbehaving users and then there's
OS JVM and Kafka tuning and also even
managing zookeeper which is the talk in
it of itself now if we go down the stack
and think about the underlying physical
or virtual infrastructure we have other
details to consider details like
networking growing disk volumes
monitoring and metrics and even a
sensible logging solution some more on
the operational side there are version
upgrades as in even just for Kafka
forget about everything else how do you
upgrade to a new version of Kaka and
more specifically what do you do when
faced with breaking changes and lastly
how do you tech detect when the
underlying servers or disk have been
corrupted and then proceed to automate
some sensible replacement strategy so
the good thing is that Heroku we offer a
cap Apache Kafka as a fully managed
service with the goal of taking care of
a lot of these operational burdens for
you so that you can focus on writing
data intensive applications and moving
on and speaking of
Chinn we currently run hundreds of
clusters in production and solve these
clusters run thousands of partitions per
broker and we've observed that
individual clusters have been processing
up to about 150 megabytes per second
sustained so about 13 terabytes a day
and this is for produced and consumed
traffic with about five milliseconds or
under five milliseconds of latency on a
message we also operate in data centers
around the world where all of our
brokers and zookeeper nodes or striped
across availability zones for better
fault tolerance and we also have our
partitions placed in a rack aware manner
for the same reasons so this is great
but it took a lot of work to get here
and we were specifically interested in
pushing the limits of Kafka at scale so
that we could get ahead of any potential
challenges that might come up so that
our users wouldn't have to face them in
production so what did we do we went out
and build tons of internal tooling and
infrastructure around these cases that
eventually surfaced a variety of
challenges for operating coffee at scale
in today's talk we're going to cover
three of them so our earliest challenge
that we have we had to overcome had the
following observed behaviors so first we
were seeing that users were exceeding
their produced quotas for long periods
of time and this was for many users
secondly brokers were crashing and being
restarted on some regular basis and to
add to that we were seeing various
network threads on the brokers getting
null pointer exceptions the major
insight here was with quotas though for
context at Heroku we leveraged Kafka's
quota implementation although quotas and
Kafka might not be implemented in the
way you think
you see Costco favors a traffic shaping
mechanism over traffic policing where
the motivation is to avoid dropping
messages when users exceed their quota
now what this happened what happens here
is that quotas can either be produce be
enforced on the producer side or the
consumer side to make things a little
bit more confusing but fortunately in
this case we're only concerned with the
produce quotas so we're going to talk
about that so what does this look like
from the users perspective or from the
users perspective when a user exceeds
their quota the request will get placed
onto an internal queue where a cop
coding controls the rate of which those
requests leave the queue
therefore Kafka essentially makes sure
that the user is in compliance with
their quota set in place now this comes
with the real cost of that there needs
to be enough space on the broker to hold
all of these queued requests but the
good thing think the good thing here is
that Kafka makes sure is that it stores
only what's necessary however it turns
out that there was a bug out of memory
error Java heats space as you can see
here you can guess what's happening
there with some gradual growth and heap
that grew out of control and eventually
exhausted all of the on heat memory so
hang on here let's let's take a step
back look at the symptoms brokers were
crashing being restarted on a regular
basis the reason for this was most
likely as a result of users exceeding
their produce quotas because we were
getting heat problem and because Cochran
uses some traffic shaping mechanism to
enforce quotas so first thing when
dealing with heat based out of memory
errors let's grab a heap dump
you'll see on the right here a right
side of the screen here that there's a
large retained heap now this is pretty
good place to start looking but we can't
just go and tune things willy-nilly so
we should get a better understanding by
first taking a look at the produce
request lifecycle or what it means to
write messages to Kafka so if we start
at the entry point in Kafka ap is when a
broker which receives a request it'll
take that request extract the message
from it and write that message to the
underlying log on disk after that it
will wait some time for a callback to be
called in which if a user is over their
produce quota or quota period then a
delay will be computed and then it will
be put onto an internal queue to be
processed and sent back at some later
time in the future finally after that
before it returns it will remove all
references to the producer requests so
that the GC can reclaim its memory and
this is nice because after this point
the message would have already been
extracted from the request and written
to disk so if we held on to the request
after this point then we would be
unnecessarily taking up memory on the
broker but it turns out that this wasn't
entirely true Kafka wasn't actually
clearing out all of the underlying
references to the produce request so
what did we do we fall to zero this jira
turned out to actually block the release
in which we then followed up by
submitting a patch upstream this patch
got reviewed merged in and landed in
Kafka 10 - so you should probably
upgrade Kafka so that was our first
issue he based on a memory our second
issue we faced had a slightly different
behavior so let's take a look at some of
the symptoms
first we were seeing that brokers were
seeing some cascading failures all
throughout the cluster then we were also
seeing that some brokers were being
restarted and then when they go to start
back up they weren't able to however in
some cases brokers were able to boot up
but then they would suddenly fail again
out of nowhere
so let's dig in first you shouldn't
expect services to be available a
hundred percent of the time in
distributed systems things can fail and
this is especially true for us since we
host our services on AWS where boxes can
go up and down at any time but still
this was pretty odd that our brokers
were failing regularly and even more odd
that when they try to come back up they
just couldn't at all so to get a deeper
understanding of that let's first take a
look at Kafka's H a model then what
happens when a broker goes down and then
finally what happens when a broker comes
back up so for Costco's h a model Kafka
has a concept of leaders and followers
where rights and reads are designated to
various leaders in the cluster and then
followers are other brokers that simply
just continuously pull from their
respective leaders now recall that
brokers have topics and topics have one
or more partitions so in this example
we'll see that the user events topic has
three partitions p0 p1 and p2 where the
broker on the left is lead for partition
0 and the broker up top is lead for
partition 1 and so on now consider the
line in the middle it says replicated
here which means that the user events
topic is replicated so in other words
the partitions are individually
replicated onto other brokers so again
in this example broke on the left is
lead 4 partition 0 but
it's also followers for partition one
and two broke on the top is leave for
partition one but then also followers
for partition zero and two
so in essence Kafka tries to balance
leadership among brokers so that it can
basically say that a partition is lead
for only a subset of all the partitions
in the cluster so illustrate that
further say we ignore a replication
factor for a second and we have five
brokers one topic and fifty partitions
in this case a broker will be lead for
about ten partitions on average or 50
partitions divided by five brokers and
in other words a broker will process
both read and write requests for ten out
of 50 partitions for that given topic
now if we consider replication factor
with it being set to three on the topic
we'll see that there will be two
additional copies for each partition
ideally living on other brokers in the
cluster and I say ideally because it
doesn't have to but it should
so again replication is pull based where
brokers also may act as a follower and
they continuously pull messages from
their leaders now I would like to add
that each leader maintains something
called an in sync replica set or ISR and
these is ours essentially just represent
all followers that are currently caught
up to the leader now if a follower is
being lagged for whatever reason or it
just completely got stuck then the
leader will then remove the follower
from its ayats are and this is
especially important for when brokers
failover because on a failover only
followers that are in the ISR currently
may be elected as a new leader
so that's Kafka's H a model now let's
take a look at what happens exactly when
a broker goes down so first in Kafka
there's something called a controller
there is one of them per cluster and
this controller manages states of
partitions and replicas using state
machines and replicas is just another
name for a follower with that said it's
incredibly important for the controller
so that the state machine is allowed to
administrate tasks such as determining
which brokers are leader for which
partitions on cases where things fail
over for instance now the partition
specifically internally has many
different states and state transitions
today we're interested in the case where
a partition transitions from the online
state into the offline partition state
and this will happen for generally many
partitions at once because when a broker
goes down then since its lead for many
subsets of all partitions in a cluster
then all of those partitions will go
down as well so as for failing or going
down for the brokers there are two cases
clean and unclean shut down on a clean
shut down a broker will initiate a
controlled shutdown sequence where it
sends a request to the controller the
controller will see that and then it
will preemptively move partition
leadership off of that shutting down
broker and on to a different broker
that's alive in the cluster after that
it will send the response back to the
broker in which that shutting down
broker will proceed on with its local
shutdown task on an unclean shutdown it
works a little bit differently since the
brokers won't necessarily be able to
notify the controller that is shutting
down so for a little bit of context when
a broker boots up it will first read
mr. itself and zookeeper and basically
it just writes some metadata saying that
it's alive and it does this by writing
in a femoral Z node so when a broker
goes down when it dies so does the
zookeeper session when the zookeeper
session dies the ephemeral Z node goes
away now the controller in the cluster
will have listeners that listen listen
for these types of events where it'll
take all of the partitions that that
down broker was Lear for and then move
them into the offline partition state
and it does this simply by just writing
some metadata to a map locally after
that it'll take those freshly offline
partitions and then I'll transition them
back into the online partition state but
this time on to another live broker on
the cluster so that's what happens when
a broker goes down now what happens when
it comes back up well when a broker
starts up it has to initialize many
things and among these things there's
one important one which is the log
manager and essentially what this thing
does is it makes sure that the broker
completely reads all of the partitions
from disk and into memory when a broker
starts up after that the broker will
register itself in zookeeper telling the
cluster that is alive as we just
described and then it will begin
stretching messages from their
respective leaders under normal
operation okay so that was that for
shutting down but what's the point of
all this well the major insight here is
that that's a lot of work that's a lot
of work that brokers need to do when a
failover occurs and that's a lot of work
for brokers to do when restarts happen
essentially work is a function of the
number of partitions on a broker more
partitions means more work and more work
means more time required for brokers to
recover when they boot up
so this could take a while if you
remember we run thousands of partitions
per broker and unfortunately at the time
our automation didn't consider this so
our automation although it would restart
brokers just fine all day recovery would
take longer than expected where our
automation would catch this detect it
timeout the broker and proceed to
restart it again and this would happen
repeatedly essentially our automation
was little too aggressive so what did we
do we introduced the recovery state into
our automations own state machine so
that it would allow brokers enough time
to recover without interfering in
addition to that we added additional
modern and alerting around the case
where recovery takes unusually long but
in this case we page a human rather than
attempting automatic remediation so that
was our second issue we faced the third
and more recent issue had a similar
behavior but this time it was less
straightforward let's take a look at the
observed behaviors first we were seeing
long periods of stability everything was
behaving just fine then one day suddenly
Broker started crashing and to make
matters worse when brokers trying to
boot up they were crashing at various
stages of the boot up process so this
wasn't a deterministic thing and finally
we were seeing unreplicated partitions
to make matters worse and also brokers
were seeing request timeouts from
various inner broker communications and
this time it was for certain that our
automation was not interfering so recall
that when brokers boot up they need to
load all of their partitions now
if you think about it what does it
exactly mean to load a partition how
does this exactly work internally so
let's again the anatomy of a partition
which is also sometimes called a log
consists of many or a sequence of many
log segments and these log segments are
created under some frequency that's
determined by when a log should be
rolled which is determined by either
time or size so if you look in the
example here if a log is rolled every
three hours then you'll end up with
eight log segments per day so an
aggregate that amounts to many files on
disk there many log segments there and
remember we have thousands of partitions
per broker that's a lot of file
descriptors we were seeing tons and tons
being created as long as we're being
rolled
so again logs completely load all their
partitions and log segments now I would
like to add that Kafka does try to do a
good job in making sure that brokers
only use file descriptors for only the
active log segments and where this TVA's
is when logs are currently being rolled
as you may know because the broker will
temporarily hold on the file descriptors
for old log segments until the roll is
complete so if we look back at the opera
services operational logs the logs that
you're normally used to the tale F you
will see the following i'll exception
too many files in the system what does
this mean well we need more file
descriptors we were completely maxing
out on our limit and what did we do to
fix this we increase the limit on the
process and the system as well this is
in this disk control and the limits
caused or the idea is to basically
reserve enough for the process and
have or maintain is sufficiently large
enough buffer for the rest of the system
so as a general rule of thumb we
recommend about one and a half file
descriptors per long segment and now
technically log segments consists of
three actual files on disk the data
index and time index files hover through
our expensive testing we did find that
it was about one and a half per log
segment and this is for many reasons and
one of which is that Kafka again tries
to hold on to file descriptors only for
the active log segments but the more
important thing to consider are the
number of inputs that are involved when
thinking about this problem first you
need to consider the number of topics
and their partitions and the replication
factor then you take that divide it by
the number of brokers then you have to
consider your log segments basically how
many logs you have and how often they're
rolled calculate that against the
retention time and then you come up with
those two resultant you multiply them
together multiply them again by a buffer
in this case 1.5 and then you get your
configuration so we did exactly that
but our brokers were still not able to
boot still not yet anyway so if we dig
deeper and look at some of the observed
behaviors will see that our brokers were
failing in a cascading way they were
being restarted not able to boot up
automation wasn't interfering some
brokers did boot but then suddenly died
again not sure what's going on here so
let's take a look back at the logs and
we'll see three different errors first
on replica fetcher thread on a fetch
kafka storage exception while appending
to a log
any request handler when broadcasting
metadata Iowa exception map failed and
lastly in a cough curse server starter
thread fatal error during startup
prepare to shut down another IO
exception map failed this is all over
the place so could this be another out
of memory problem or could this be
another another memory leak well the
funny thing is that memory wasn't even
being saturated on these brokers at the
time of the crashes GC logs were
behaving just fine or the GC was
behaving just fine we're getting
acceptable evacuation pause times keep
pressure was totally fine cross-checking
that with the system memory using H top
we see the same behavior about five gigs
out of 16 utilized but now if you take a
closer look at the log you'll see that
it references something called the file
channel implementation the map method
now if we dig into that map method in
the C code will see that it references
native memory specifically it tries to
allocate memory mapped byte buffers now
this makes sense because kafka
internally heavily leverages native
memory but basically this was not a heat
problem the problem though was a small
one where Cochrane uses native memory
for many different things and these
kinds of things aren't readily apparent
and the GC logs or heap dumps though
fortunately there are many other ways to
diagnose these types of problems we
chose to investigate by correlating
various jmx metrics using various JMX
tooling so if we look back at the log
will see that it references the request
Handler and one of them so we thought
could this be an issue around the
network something around the network
parts of the code well to dig in
we look at Costco's Network processor
threads in our case we have three of
them and we're looking for the idol
percentage of these threads where if you
look at the top basically it was a
hundred percent idle everywhere okay so
we weren't sure if this was legit so we
wanted to correlate this with some other
metrics so next we looked at the request
queue size mbean as you can see at the
top again it says zero basically no
requests were in flight but we were
sending requests so that was pretty odd
so still not sure a little bit more
confident but still needed to dig so we
dig some more and after some more
digging after some time we found out
that we were quite confident that the
problem wasn't a result of some issue
with a network part of the code great so
now what we'll remember we are dealing
with the native memory problem here and
not a heat problem so where do we look
next we look at n io and specifically we
look at the buffer pool map M beam we
check out the count and what did we find
we found out that our map byte buffers
we're growing uncontrollably
okay this was our smoking gun so piling
on top of this we cross-check that with
the system all you do is check out proc
with PID on maps take them all up and
count them up what do we get that's a
lot of memory Maps so with that in mind
firstly why would this cause brokers to
fail we had plenty of memory disk and
other resources on the brokers to handle
these cases but actually that was a lie
if you take a look here we check out
praxis vm max map count
we get a result of 65535 maximum memory
counts okay that sounds like a lot or a
little
not sure what's the context here I mean
it seems fine but wait remember that
we're running many partitions on a
broker where these partitions have many
log segments and these log segments must
be loaded and read completely when a
broker boots up so think about it again
is that a lot of memory Maps well if
you're doing some thinking about the JVM
case you'll see that just to cover it
we were running 64-bit JVM so there's no
funny business going on here
okay so pause think about it again is
that a lot of memory Maps
well yes it was it turns out that we
didn't have enough memory mapped regions
available to us but why does this matter
because our brokers were surviving
restarts in the past for the longest
time and this was just another day
another day in the operational side of
things but there was also another thing
in that we weren't able to reproduce
this in our staging environments however
there was a subtle difference log
rolling so we needed not there to be
enough traffic or retention to force
enough logs to be rolled so that it
would in turn create more log segments
which then would result in more memory
map files being required on a boot up so
this is why memory looks fine during a
sudden crash and this is why brokers
would crash when they go to recover
their logs so what did we do we fixed it
we fix this by increasing the limit on
the VM max map count and the idea is
similar to before where you want to
preserve enough for the process while
maintaining a
efficiently an armed large enough buffer
for the system so great our brokers were
able to boot successfully once again
although that was definitely a lot of
file descriptors and memory maps that we
saw so for completeness we ran with this
configuration in staging for a little
while longer
under heavy load so that enough logs
would be rolled on a frequent basis we
had retention set quite high so that we
could rule out the potential for another
leak scenario but this time instead of
the heap we wanted to rule it out in the
case for file descriptors or an or
memory maps after all of that everything
turned out to be fine so to wrap up
today we covered about we covered Kafka
and its internals it's pretty nice and
flexible in that it can satisfy many
different things in production but what
this flexibility comes a real
operational complexity trade-off where
there are many things to configure and
understand deep down at scale and
fortunately at Roku we offer a patch
Kafka it's a fully managed service so
you don't have to worry about that we
take care a lot of the operational
burdens for you so that you can focus on
writing your data intensive applications
today we cover three different points of
our journey in our time operating Kafka
in production we covered how quotas work
and how we discovered a really sparking
heat based on a memory bug around quota
management and how we ship the patch
that landed in 10 - we covered how Kafka
achieves a che and a specific case where
our automation was aggressively
remediating brokers on recovery and
finally we also covered how partitions
are implemented in Kafka internally and
what kinds of resources they need again
i'm jess chao you can reach me at jay
chou at Heroku comm if you want to chat
I'm happy to I'm happy to chat about all
things Kafka this should be a system
and streaming data infrastructure I'll
be around during the rest of the
conference and during office hours thank
you thank you so if anyone has a
question we have a few minutes now you
get to quote out no more than three
questions per conference okay for your
second case I know I didn't follow why
do you why were you why was your
automation constantly restarting
brookers so the question was why was our
automation restarting brokers in the
second case well that's because the
brokers in our configuration have many
thousands of partitions on them and
there are many different things to do
when a broker comes up and goes down or
goes down and comes up and basically it
might take a while for per broker for it
to recover so our automation taught
would time it out as it goes to recover
and then it would just restart it in the
middle of recovery
so it's essentially to detect a possibly
failed recovery and resolve it by
kicking off another restart which was
right if every so the question was the
follow-up was that is it like a time
thing right that correct yeah I mean it
so it was restarting something that was
trying to recover that was the goal of
the automation that's correct
so the broker would try to recover just
fine but then the automation would be a
little too aggressive and it would shut
it down and let it try again because it
would say that it's taking too long but
it was legitimately taking too long
because there's lots of things to do for
where for when a broker starts up if
there are many partitions on the broker
okay so I guess I've heard that people
who run Kafka sort of restart because
when they get into a weird state the way
out of that state is to restart it sort
of like the windows laptop problem right
so you definitely don't want to restart
anything in a distributed systems like
Windows laptop you want to do it in a
controlled manner in general because
there's you might have various problems
that are associated with that
thundering her
different cash issues you don't know
depends on the system but in this
particular case you want to treat the
different states of when a broker
restarts independently so it's down it's
starting up is stabilizing and it's
recovering so the case where it's
recovering you might not know how long
it takes to recover depending on what
your configuration is the point is you
have to balance between the time to
detect the problem and the time to take
action if you want to detect it and act
quickly potentially you could get very
quick restarts on your system and get
back to availability again but that
might not work in every case because
some cases you might want to take some
more time to restart thank you hi why
did you decide to change the configs in
the box itself rather than maybe like
putting fewer partitions on a machine or
like increasing the segment size so it's
a good question the question is why did
you why didn't you just limit the number
of partitions now that certainly would
be an option but and that's certainly a
thing you can do since kafka skills
pretty well horizontally if you are
running into partitions problems just
add more boxes however that might not be
the most cost effective way of dealing
with things you want to kind of enjoy
every single amount of performance that
you can on a box and then after that if
you're seeing diminishing returns or
signs of it or some other trade-off that
you aren't willing to make then you can
scale it out so we thought that was
would it would be a worthwhile effort to
see what an individual broker could do
and also in addition to that no one has
really dealt with that type of thing and
before and with that we were able to
surface a number a handful of bugs that
we've patched for upstream as well some
of them are in 10 - some of them I think
are 10 to 1 which was released today and
I think some our schedule would be
scheduled for point 11 but still up in
the air for that